hello fellow Guardians hope your first
week of destiny 2 was as fun as mine
here's a quick guide on how to get the
exotic scout rifle might a multi-tool a
classic from destiny don't forget we
also have a guide on how to get the
exotic hand cannon sturm so make sure
you hit that sub button for more destiny
2 guides first and foremost you'll need
to finish the campaign and be at least
around 260 power level this is a
recommended power level for the mission
enhance trigger the enhance mission at
the II DZ when you're ready to proceed I
won't go into the details about the
mission as to try not to spoil too much
finish the various steps of this mission
and it will ultimately lead you back to
dead rooms to get the mighty mini tools
submachine gun once you get that head
back to see Banshee 44 in the tower as a
pro tip hopefully you have rare Scout
saved up because you'll need them for
the next part if you don't make sure to
start saving them as you'll need them
for the next part of the quest
technically you can break down legendary
Scouts too but they net you the same as
a rare Scout 1 out of 5 talk to banshee
and you'll have a new mission for you
the first part of the mission tells you
to get 50% headshots with a scout and
also to get 25 multi kills with a scout
without reloading after you finish that
part head back to Banshee 44 for another
mission this time around he wants you to
break down 5 valuable Scouts
as mentioned before hopefully you had
some saved up otherwise you'll have to
farm them remember legendary still only
count as one after breaking down 5 scout
rifles you have one more mission to do
for Banshee 44 use the mind a mini
multi-tool to get 50 kills while in the
air once you've accomplished that head
back to Banshee 44 for your good ol
might a multi-tool another pro tip here
I would mention is if you have the
patience to wait get as high of a power
level as you can before turning it in my
mind a multi-tool ended up being 283
power level another good tip is that if
you happen to make another character
this quest is repeatable and can roll
higher power level
also you can shortcut your second Maite
by equipping the Mitel mini multi-tool
this will skip the enhanced mission and
allow you to talk to Banshee 44 for the
steps that I mentioned above
good luck Guardians and stay tuned a
GameSpot for more guides and features
for destiny too